all right you good yeah fixing the girls
[Music]
Morgan coming back to our TV screens
yeah for this I'm so excited to be on
RuPaul's Drag Race two all-star season
three it's gonna be a party
why was now the time to do all stars
because I cannot imagine this is the
first time they'll called you to do it
well we're just gonna have to leave that
to myth I just feel like it's time to go
compete again and let the new kids the
new fans see what's up and see how
old-school girls do it I look pretty
good for a dead did any jaws drop when
you walked into that workroom well all
of them of course I mean I'm the most
beautiful thing on two legs no of course
it was good to see the girls when we
walked in and we saw everybody and you
know you kind of measure up your
competition when you get in there and a
friendly sisterly way yesterday but
you're like I could kill her in a
lip-sync I might you know send her home
I could be cool with her it's an organic
thing from the girls from season two one
and three and we just didn't care we
were just out for blood and I think that
was gonna help take me to the end of the
competition okay out for blood that is
intense
yeah you know we're all still friends
and sisters but this is not kumbaya
corner is it is it easier or harder to
compete with Queens you know easier
better to the double you know right who
would you size up as your biggest
competition myself actually
I'm my own biggest competition I'm not
worried about anybody else
what kind of Morgan are we gonna see
same old good better makeup one thing
I'm not a big fan of is diva dome I'm
gonna have to smack that down a little
bit how has the show changed from season
two to all-stars three what's the
biggest difference for you the
challenges keep getting harder and
harder each season drew is blowing
boomerangs with these girls and trap
doors and surprise surprise surprise
yeah they kind of rewrite the rule book
every season of all-stars so what can we
expect from all-stars three face crack
that's this is going to be face cracking
the challenges are out of control every
single episode is gonna gag the face
and today what you guys watch it your
jaws just pull them up off the floor and
I told yourself
it's interesting how RuPaul pushes you
and your character and your aesthetic
and dragon what you think you can't do
she pushes to make sure you do it
because if she could do it she's looking
for the drag superstar that can do it as
well and she was more beautiful this
time than like I saw her last time I'm
like how do you get more beautiful well
you know those are government secrets I
know that is area 51
whenever Roo walks into the room is this
kind of thing she has something about
her just kind of makes you get the
butterflies inside ethereal Fagor
yes that kind of magnetic pull and then
there's Michelle o pity's getting judged
by Michelle is of course a rite of
passage
it is we didn't have she wasn't on
season two we had Merle who I adore but
I wanted what that Viper tundle Michelle
I want you to read that two layers of
skin off my back I love her and did she
I can't tell you that you're just gonna
stay tuned and watch
[Music]
you